the plan is to retire here you know what
i mean that that is my plan but
obviously you know those things handle
themselves when all you have to do is
just go on the field and perform do the
right things on and off the field um and
those things will take care of itself
i'm really overwhelmed but at the same
time man it's so surreal um to be around
great a great organization like seattle
um and to to be coached by
legendary coaches hall of fame coaches
playing with hall-of-famers
from russ to bobby kj bruce irvin
um quandre the list goes on and on man
i'm just excited to be to be here um i'm
here to help and you know i can't wait
to get out there in front of the 12.
as jamal adams you know peter he stopped
himself from saying it's it's wonderful
to be around great players and set a
great organization instead and i point
that out because
that was one of his many complaints
during his time with the jets one week
ago when he went all in on adam gase
that was not the first time that jamal
adams expressed displeasure he had a
long list of grievances that would
bubble up from time to time after his
rookie season in 2017 he did a radio
appearance where he said a lot of these
guys are just doing the bare minimum
they really don't care todd bowles the
coach at the time had to clean up that
mess then after they lost to the browns
week three of 2018 when baker mayfield
came in to save the day when tyrod
taylor got hurt jamal adams went public
and said we didn't have a game plan for
baker mayfield todd bowles had to come
in and clean up that mess there have
been times when adam said we don't have
enough good players we need to get
players it's been one after another this
is what he's craved he's wanted to go to
a team that has the deck stack like it
was when he was at lsu now he finally
gets it and he's happy for now but this
is a guy who's shown all due respect
over his three seasons in the league if
there's something he doesn't like he's
going to sound off about it and it'll be
interesting to see if and when he sounds
off about something he may not like in
seattle
jamal adams has been a lot like uh frank
costanza on the festivus
[Laughter]
because he clearly has had a lot of
problems with the jets and and again
mike i'm going to take this
in a way in in a direction that uh
you didn't you didn't lead me into but i
want to say this
so to me
i think this needs to be an awakening
and a reckoning for the new york jets
organization
every time with the exception of sam
darnold because quarterbacks can't leave
but with the exception of sam darnold
every time they've gotten a high draft
pick good player
okay in the last 10 years he never stays
never ever ever wait a minute wait
how many have they had we have matt
casey well in position
how about how about mohamed wilkerson
and how about sheldon richardson they
were good players and somehow someway it
all crumbled
all i'm saying is that you know it's all
well and good
for the new york jets to have two ones
in each of the next two years it's all
well and good for the jets to have five
picks in the first three rounds next
year that's great by the way in what
will probably be one of the most
uncertain drafts in nfl history
but it's all well and good but at some
point at some point
joe douglas has to build a team where
people want to stop
wanting off the island
that is the vital thing for the new york
jets you can have all the wonderful
draft picks you want but if they all
grow up dying to play for the seattle
seahawks and the kansas city chiefs or
anybody but the new york jets what good
is it
that's why it's vital
that as much as vital as they pick good
players it's just as vital that they
build a good culture
porn it really has been a disaster under
john itzick and then mike mccagnin and
joe douglas has only been there for a
relatively short period of time and look
i think they know what they need to do
and it starts at the top and it's gone
from woody johnson to christopher
johnson with this vague sense that at
some point woody's going to come back
um and and uh yeah i look
it's a wake-up call on one hand for the
jets but on the other hand i am still
astonished they got what they got for a
guy who was doing everything he could to
tear down the building on his way out
the door i would have not believed a
week ago today if you had told me
they're going to get two first-round
picks a safety to replace him a third
round pick for jamal adams and a four
even if they're both picked number 32 in
round one they're still first-round
picks i would have never thought that
would happen and you know to the extent
that they were working on the deal ahead
of time and that it basically was done i
believe as of last friday i got to give
the seahawks credit for not squeezing
the jets to take less because after adam
said what he said last week you very
easily could have squeezed the jets to
take less because it's not like somebody
else was going to give them anything
close once adam set the building on fire
uh correction they didn't get a three
and a four they swapped a three with a
four right that's what i said for jamal
adams and for they got two ones and a
three and a safety
so but but i would make this point i
would make this point
i know nobody
abides by this draft trade chart okay
but if you add up the average draft
position of where the seahawks have
picked in the last five years in the
first round before they start trading
because john schneider always trades is
one or almost always does if you add
that up
it doesn't equal the sixth pick in the
draft so in other words they've their
average has been 23. so
you couldn't trade those two ones for
jamal adams now i understand you also
have to page them all adams and that's
part of this but my point in this is
i would have done this every day of the
week and twice on sunday if i was the
seattle seahawks especially because the
last five guys they've picked high in
the draft
not including uh their pick this year
last five guys have been all very
questionable players none of whom are
stalwarts for their team right now
so i think this was in my opinion an
easy decision for john schneider and one
other thing right one other thing
just think of this okay
what is the draft going to be like next
year we've danced around this a little
bit
but what happens if a bunch of players
in the sec in acc what happens if they
start opting out okay what happens if
10 or 12 or so first round talents
opt out of their college football season
and you have to judge them only
on their 2019 season tape so again i'm
not saying that's the biggest thing in
the world but in my opinion the draft
pick in 2021
has a good chance to be devalued
well and i'll tell you what the other
reality is somebody's going to get joe
burrow a lot lower than the first pick
in the draft because if there wouldn't
have been a 2019 season no way in hell
joe burrows in the top 20 if even in the
first round so it's good and bad it
makes it more of a crap shoot and
frankly frankly you can make the
argument that having a low first round
pick not all that bad because there's a
chance that better players are going to
slip through by virtue of the fact that
there's a bigger chance though there's a
bigger chance though that that you might
draft a bust
i mean because you're not gonna have as
much knowledge
yeah
there's one element of the jamal adams
trade that you touched on briefly and i
think we we need to to highlight this
just a bit you know i know we live in a
time where unusual behavior through
repetition becomes normalized but that's
kind of what we're seeing in the nfl and
it started last september with the
texans it continued with
the rams up making a trade for multiple
first-round picks for a guy still on his
rookie contract without extending him
the box that puts you in look at what
the texans ultimately had to pay
laramie tunsil 22 million a year in new
money on only a three-year deal which is
unheard of for a second contract for a
high-profile player the rams are screwed
with jalen ramsey two ones and a four
he's going into his option year he holds
all the cards they have to pay him
market value or they're going to look
like morons for giving up what they gave
up the same thing is going to apply to
the seahawks yes they have jamal adams
for two more years peter but it's beyond
me that these teams are not insisting on
getting long-term deals done on the way
through the door because their leverage
is only going to go down as that player
begins to play and gets closer and
closer to the end of the contract
because of everything you gave up to get
him
can't argue with you mike one thing that
that i don't know
i had heard that uh the seahawks did not
want to do a deal with jamal adams right
now for 2020 cap reasons okay
now 2021
they're going to be able to sign jamal
adams to in my opinion what probably
will be a market value contract but
think of this mike market value in 2021
might have changed from market value
2019 depending on what's going on in the
economy depending on what's going on in
uh
you know in the cratering of the salary
cap let's just say but
as of this morning the seattle seahawks
are 26th
in money committed to the cap in 2021 at
146 million the reason why that is
significant
it isn't just a fake number they do not
have a big star
in 2021 that they quote have to take
care of
and so i look at that and i say well you
know the seahawks were in a little bit
of trouble this year on the cap and
probably didn't want to pay out more
cash this year in an uncertain season
so i i understood why they waited until
next year although you know we'll see
how it goes if it ends up that they end
up paying three million more on average
per year than they could have gotten for
this year then obviously it'll look like
a mistake
peter had seahawks gm john schneider on
his podcast this week and peter asked
schneider if this younger crop of gm's
in the league from schneider to brett
veach chris ballard etc are more willing
to pull the trigger on big deals here's
some of what schneider had to say
i think that you're you also
have experienced a gap in
i don't want to say generations but now
they're you know they're when you're
when you're dealing with other general
managers you have guys that are
uh
similar in age and in in closer and
experienced there was a pretty big gap
there for a while where
you know there were guys that were you
know 15
20
you know 25 years older than me that you
didn't have that same type of
relationship with or
you know uh so i think there this group
is
is is much more um is is easier to deal
with i don't think there's a lot of
people that are that are out there
trying to just completely try to take
advantage of people and and i'm not
saying that happened in the past but i
mean i'm sure that there were certain uh
people that thought that you know they
could they could do a better job than
others and that's that's fair that's you
know that would be their prerogative and
their confidence and their staff and how
they approach acquisition
you know with us
when when you look at our guys you know
when we moved back and took malik
mcdowell we thought that you know we
thought that was a great
great move and and you know
i talked about this and you and i have
talked about this after every draft you
know it's it's almost like you're done
you get done talking to a group of
surgeons that have come out of a
operation where you never nobody really
comes out of there going you know that
was just okay like that commercial right
you know like
like somebody just got reinstated right
that one you know so uh you always feel
good about it you know we lost malik in
a tragic tragic you know uh four-wheeler
incident
and you know was never able to play
football again rashad
uh rashad penny you know we had probably
the best medical grade we ever had on
anybody and he comes in and gets hurt
right away you know so and then lj
collier last year you know nobody's even
seen him yet we thought we were going to
lose him for this season he had a you
know very uh rough like kind of mba-ish
high ankle sprain and so there's these
they're these they're these guys that we
you know there's there's there's still
yes i understand you know the malik
situation and that you know that's a
that's a bummer uh
you know for everybody himself included
um but
you know the other two guys people
haven't really truly seen yet so
we're excited about those guys and you
know we're excited about a ton of young
guys in the team and it's pretty cool to
see like you know tyler lockett you know
finally getting up there you know we got
two receivers in the top hundred players
that the players voted on it's excited
to see chris carson get into that group
and so i think there's a number of uh
of of young talented guys that were that
were excited about who were excited
about this last class too and
when you when you when you when you sit
back and you're and you're you're
constantly preaching to your staff about
you know what can we do every day to get
better
and you're adding somebody of jamal's uh
intensity and dog and
instincts and you know he's he's just an
incredible incredible football player so
uh we just felt like it was it was an
opportune time uh we love bradley
mcdougall great guy
he's a pro day in day out the jets are
going to love him
but you know we we just we just couldn't
pass on this and and uh you know that we
pride ourselves on
um
not just the first round but you know
three through um seven and then how
important is rookie free agency we
started a super bowl with two
uh rookie free agent wide receivers you
know so uh
we take a lot of pride in in the whole
process and not just the first round the
first round ends up just being the
entertainment portion of of uh what the
draft looks like
as josh schneider with peter king you
can hear the entire podcast wherever you
find your podcast and you know look
there is i think peter an importance of
doing deals that feel like a win-win you
don't want to crush a guy on a trade
because then that guy's always going to
be gun shy about doing another trade
with you i can remember back when andy
reid was flipping his backup
quarterbacks to anyone and everyone for
second round picks and they all stunk
not that reed was trying to screw them
but he was just so good at coaching
quarterbacks and no one else was that
people were giving up too much for the
quarterback so people got gun shy about
trading for andy reid backup
quarterbacks i mean you don't want to
have a reputation of winning trades
because then no one's going to trade
with you
yeah and i think in this particular case
mike that you know i'm writing a little
bit about this in my column for monday
you know i think there's a really
interesting point to be made
that in the old days you know when i
started covering football in the 80s i
covered the giants for four years george
young who was the general manager of the
giants
you know you you would hardly ever see
him make
uh you know a trade of significance
really you know he would make draft
choice trades but teams in those days
for the most part were not trading for
veterans or weren't unloading their own
players unless it was for you know a
draft pick just to get something back
what's changed now
is that the confluence of players
wanting too much money
players
looming to be free agents soon
teams are saying let's get as much as we
can now especially in the case like the
jets they knew they probably weren't
going to be able to sign them long term
they made a great deal for the situation
that they were in right now and the
other part of it
chris ballard eric decosta john
schneider brandon bean
un afraid howie roseman tom telesco
chris greer
un afraid and so that is one of the
differences it used to be that draft
choices were gold jimmy johnson started
to break that mold
good for him
he would trade with anybody trade
anything but the point is these guys
today they think more about what's best
for my team and if i have to give up a
little bit too much so be it
of course jimmy johnson ended up getting
the foundation for a team that won three
super bowls by trading herschel walker
for every draft pick vikings for three
years
uh but yeah but you know you're right i
mean look and maybe it's not not so much
the draft pick itself but
the idea that where the pick is
once you get out of the top five it
really is a complete and total crap
shoot you really don't know what's going
to happen with the guy schneider was
talking about how hey we got rashad
penny highest medical grade we've ever
had he gets injured right away so um
those picks and where those picks are
may not be as critical you want to have
as many lottery tickets as you can
because you never know which one you're
going to scratch off and becomes an
all-pro but
maybe this this new wave of gms is more
willing to recognize who cares about a
low first round draft pick just because
the first round pick it it's no
guarantee we're gonna get a star player
we know we're getting a guy we have
certainty here we're getting a guy who's
gonna come in and make our defense a lot
better and i think that's what these
players are recognizing
mike one other quick point i think that
where these guys
have learned their trade eric decosta
learns from ozzie newsome
uh john schneider learns from ron wolf
and i think where these guys learn their
trade
is part of this because honestly you
know john schneider has told me this
before you know like he he chuckles
when it might be mentioned and boy
you're getting ripped for that trade i
mean
you think john schneider cares what the
columnist in
you know in in new york or l.a or even
seattle is is ripping his trade oh you
gave away too much he just doesn't he
was trained that way from ron wolfe
yeah that's a great point and uh we'll
see how this trade goes it's going to
take some time to see what the jets do
with the picks but you know on hey this
one
this one i you know at first i thought
how in the hell did the jets get
anything for this guy
uh the seahawks gave up too much but i
understand it now and i agree and after
hearing schneider talk on your podcast
you know this falls into a potential
win-win category let's see how adams
does in seattle let's see how he deals
with adversity in seattle let's see if
pete carroll you know pete carroll's
dealt with some big personalities in the
past let's see if carol can deal with
jamal adams and uh you could have up
you know a very very important weapon in
that seattle defense peter in an offense
uh or a division that is swinging
towards some great offenses with what
they have in san francisco and what's
coming in arizona and what the rams
still have and uh jamal adams could be
the guy who makes that difference it was
so thin we talked earlier about the
seahawks 49ers rivalry it was so thin of
a margin that got the 49ers the top seed
last year and kept the seahawks from
winning the division jamal adams
single-handedly seems to be enough to
push that pendulum in the seahawks
direction
very much could be because both of those
games last year
were absolutely 51-49 games
you know
you know on a scale of 100 who's going
to win this game i mean it's just it's
absolutely razor razor thin
and look i thought of that when this
trade was made mike the first thing i
thought of is that game 256 in the nfl
last year
if jamal adams was it was on the seattle
seahawks last year would he have made
enough of a difference
i mean
maybe maybe not but i think there's a
good chance he would have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports